welcome to this video and coverage of
Tata Steel 2014 let's have a look at
Round 4 plate today after rest day we
have the some new round in the a group
on how is it count they have a new name
for that masters or something all right
let's have a look at the games we had um
three draws today out of six games and
I'm going to start with drawers and make
it relatively brief um in the comparison
there really yeah far less interesting
than the decisive game so let's let's
start um first game is fun Bailey
against them hari krishna from from
India I Krishna i think is the winner of
them did he win the last year p group no
that's neither droid all right so let's
let's see what happened this game am I
will go through really really quickly
because it was a fairly uneventful
affair we have on me and Catalan with
Quincy do and a for this line is
actually a bit more um yeah can you say
ambitious than green takes you for yeah
maybe you can at least it it's a bit
more complicated this position type but
the way it this is plate now Maya both
players it did really quickly fizzles
out black has managed to put a night on
this nice ground before and the bishop
on c6 which is nice because it deposed
is the strong Catalan bishop and black
has fair control over the central
squares this certainly looks like a
decent set up the black but the way they
both play it now and what plays Bishop
euphonik and how Bishop d5
yeah white snow is basically forced to
capture on d5 and I think you should
have avoided that somehow as the
structure after he five is really very
very dull for white I mean okay
ultimately it's dull for both sides but
white really has a hard time to to do
anything here it's very very difficult
to to make any kind of progress in this
position how do you ever break in the
center for example it's difficult and
this configuration on the queenside
means that right is never having
anything there in the game we have
further exchanges right quickly there
was about getting rid of this before
night which is very understandable and
we have a neat little tricky after night
x before of course black play screen v6
using the pin so that he doesn't really
loose material and here yeah it's simply
nothing happening in this position known
or e2 is singing but before saying as
well so not really a problem yeah and
the capital of moves later a draw was
agreed yeah this is really a completely
dead position but white has no break
black hair store break they can play
that on for ages and Louis be a draw so
draw a grid TM pretty dull affair next
game to look at is galfond against NIDA
CH the german player here playing black
did sir king's indian only recently
neither chasm taken up this opening it
yet actually fits to his uncompromising
style but still a recent addition
girlfriend goes for the the arabic but
after night a six
which is um probably nowadays you know
the main reply besides c5 he plays
Knight f3 so after those moves and e5 we
basically transpose back into a yeah
classical Kings Indian with an early
Bishop e3 and it's quite interesting
this line that black is playing an ID
for ya it's an interesting is gained the
move age 60 Bishop g5 is not on at the
moment why it needs to retreat and after
taking you place the somewhat crude
looking for Queen f6 but of course it
has a point thus night is simply hanging
and why it needs to to do something
about it okay this is also hanging but
yeah something like Bishop g4 well let's
say like takes first him something like
that is not really helping like has
active play he played night b3 back this
makes more sense attacking the night but
now black simply placed Queen edge for
and yeah white needs to react to the
major he could take but this gives black
the bishops for no particular
compensation so Bishop f4 is the movie
plate and now night edge place a simple
move Bishop b5 and just exchanges
bishops after the trade we get to a
position where we have this typical pawn
structure for the Kings in yet those
supports opposing each other and white
having played c4 which means that white
must be somewhat conscious that adds the
long run deform being a weakness and
it's not becoming an important important
factor he really am is in no trouble
here because of his superior
yeah mobilization and peace a
coordination but in general this is a
healthy structure like only needs to be
cautious here with some concrete things
after age 39 f 692 white intends to
regroup the night but like I think has
got adequate play please Rupert e8 yeah
and now notify this simplifies things a
bit it's interesting in this position
maybe Queen see one was an alternative
threatening Knight f3 after bush should
be 693 Queen f4 for example was an idea
the Queen doesn't have many squares but
I can always play age 5 to secure it
maybe why does slightly better but it's
nothing to to grade in the game after 95
we had some simplifications c6 breaking
up the D file this concrete line we have
some traits when at the end we have this
constant figuration black will attack
the pawn and use this activity and yeah
jet isn't the deep on to enter on be too
yeah we have some some more traits oops
this was this was a position where they
greet to a draw yeah there's absolutely
no headway to make here for four white
at first you think okay this is an
basically an extra pawn on d6 because
this is doubled but like has easy ideas
to attack it or maybe f5 and then
approached the pawn white cannot really
use it this pawn doing doing much it's
it's really very draw position so on the
draw is very understandable at this
point okay let's look at the third drawn
game not not spoiling materially if you
look at the games they're not that
exciting um in geary against wesley so
we had another kettle on this original
popular in this tournament it's a
general a popular opening but we had
many catalogs IAM okay yeah so is
playing the close catalan with this
insertion of Bishop before check and
retweeting the ideas after Bishop before
check and they quickly go back the idea
is that white of course needs to
interpose and whatever he's doing on
each reply has got some drawbacks Knight
c3 the drawback is that the night is
often not so I'm well placed in
connection with the capture on c4
because this pawn is not so easy to to
recapture the natural way is to move the
horn and take it like that but then why
have you played g3 if white plays 92a
but can also take and it's not easy to
keep you gained upon note that Queen H
I'm a g6 does not help at all and which
means that this is basically the move
that white is playing and after Bishop
is heaven this is really a bit of a
misplaced piece in the close Catalan
like this with c6 very often this poem
becomes an issue and the most convenient
way to play it is normally be three and
to fianchetto the bishop but now it's on
detune so you can try stuff like Bishop
to see 392 but it's just a an inferior
square compared to be too because it is
exposed on c3 so on this is really a
gain for black either sir Bishop
placement on d 2 yeah well give you
place with Queens to end mission
later this is quite quite normal now
once the bishop is on D to an artificial
fianchetto is not helping and we had
some pretty standard play some
repetitions but then why this is doing
something yeah this position type is
very standard in this in this line White
has gained to the bishops but the
bishops are not terribly active at the
moment especially the g2 bishop is just
biting on this pawn black has a slight
problem here with the queenside having
given up as light squared Bishop Bishop
this is Sir a bit weak but of course
it's still a very very solid position
for black we see that with this
regrouping he manages to block the
center and improve his pieces I don't
think that black has anything special to
fear here however in the game after some
further moves they all look look fairly
normal and it seems that white got a
little bit of pressure and actually
managed to to put some yeah to post some
problems to black in this position it's
not so easy to give black some advice if
he takes on b5 Queen B 5 is a very
annoying answer rook see one taking is
not a check so there's basically a
triple attack the queen is attacking
here it's attacking of the bishop and
the rook so it's terribly overloaded
black cannot take off v5 and via what
exactly is you move now need to be a
precise he played night we ate but after
the capture and those further moves is
having got lost and this certainly was
not not planned
I am by Wesley so before and he didn't
really want to give up the porn but it
was a bit too much pressure on the C
file but it turned out that black with
Quincy one and further activation got
quite some counter played and I'm not
sure that this is so easy for for--why
22 plane took and played Queen c3 the
computer suggestion here is the much
more aggressive Northey form but this is
a move that it's difficult to play for a
human because the shop g5 looks like a
very young yeah very tough reply with
this possible activation after ye 585 is
still this idea and you know I always
have opposite colored bishops here so
it's not easy at all to to win this
position something like that can be an
idea black has some counter play I mean
why it is the only one really hoping for
a win but it's not easy at all in the
game Quincy 30 s mansion was played and
it is quite quite similar we get a
similar position now White has played a
for later and now Knight f6 also an idea
to activate the night and I don't think
that White's extra porn on the queenside
is really that important is king as
gently bit to a bit too weak and check
black got to chatting laughs Carlton
play always note the opposite candid
bishops which are really an important
factor in assessing this position as as
being really equal ya gotta come
moves but it's basically not much
happening all right that was a brief
overview of the jaws now on let's go to
them to the decisive games that much I
can tell you as a spoiler let's start
with kayaking against a report the
Hungarian young Korean player who played
such enterprising chess at the first
three rounds playing the Budapest gambit
and one be three in the first round okay
it's playing black against kayaking and
we have the French defence and report
place all kinds of opening so hard to
prepare something specific we have the
winner on and in fact plays a very very
rare line with Queen c7 this is yeah
very well forgotten line the idea is
that all the queen is quite often
decently placed on c7 and it has an
additional a very specific idea against
Queen g4 especially considering that
after 97 24 is the main and problematic
move for for black so black is playing
that one in order to after green g4 have
an F porn ready and if white plays them
a slow move here like 93 for example
black can play 9700 supposed to the
usual structures or play b6 whatever the
Queen on c7 is quite quite decently
placed or 3g for is the critical move
and now he plays f6 this is even rarer
in comparison to f5 this has been known
for for very long time even um was
played in the 1960s bye-bye ciao and
against against against official and we
have Towe with white against what Vinny
gets on so very old line report i
replace f six which is even now even
more obscure as mentioned and that's
quite interesting at defense g7 of
course and it introduces the idea to
capture so it's a bit more aggressive
than f5 I was in 93 he played see form
yeah this is to prevent I guess the
bishop coming to d3 the drawback of
course is that it yar closes the
queenside and allows wide to activate
the bishop via a three in an ideal world
a for Bishop e3 something like that um
this in fact also would have been an
interesting with now trying to activate
the bishop here k lacking as a farm warm
my straightforward idea he just plays
each form and wants to use the bishop on
f4 we get to that young and Bishop f4
here this however is a debatable
decision and this is due to the most
night age 5 which report strangely
enough is not playing I mean I really
would have expected that to do to happen
but he played the Queen a5 an
interesting move not necessarily bad but
um this this was a quite quite simple
and and interesting note that if white
now moves to the Queen so let let's say
here playing playing simple moves black
can even consider to play Luka fade but
you can also take e five and say take
not sure if why should should
change queen son now probably not takes
now let's say queen 85 black ass God
Luke evade and this Bishop has oops not
only 6 has ideas to go here or even
after the King has has moved somewhere
Bishop d7 and all the way to g6 it's
very helpful that all nights are often
disposition like only needs to make sure
that this Bishop is playing then his
nice porn structures this is really good
fun so this is not really the problem I
guess Knight takes c6 is the main the
main issue that he was yeah Fredo I
guess but after Queen takes and this
kind of he even castle said disability
let's say here so is this kind of
position um maybe if you gave aid um
this also would have been interesting to
play for black it's not the greatest
structure ever but white is somewhat
behind in development and he needs to
coordinate his pieces first it's not not
that easy it was interesting 9h 5 EP 8
25 which is not not bad as mentioned
it's a bit more enterprising placing the
Queen on a 4 and trying to get this
count to play um yeah here in this
position surprisingly enough why did not
take on g7 plate kini 1 i'm not really
sure why it didn't take i mean i don't
really see what what the drawback is you
can you can take ok Fator sir probably
necessary and then um fairly novel found
in normal move like night like am rook
edge three looks quite okay i mean this
is an idea or maybe rook to e3 it just
has a useful role on the
rank to cover the important call on c3
black should probably take and then you
see that this Lucas nicely defending the
pond I don't really see a black speck
idea it's a bit mysterious this game I
don't I don't really know why it didn't
take on g7 that looks like just just
being a good move you played a kingly
one as mentioned and after castles black
is threatening an ID fine this certainly
is interesting for like after f3
necessary he played the very active
movie 5 and this is a move that for a
stronger and more experienced player and
yeah it is quite obvious on the smooth
activating the the bishop but move that
weaker player sometimes struggle with
giving up and healthy otherwise healthy
on a derp the peace activities found
more porn so if I vers move I like
bishop took and Bishop f5 so black is
active now with counter play here until
he needed to gather that and plate
looked way too yeah it's so probably
what you need to do if you can wait with
rube see one the a porn is a constant
volume
yeah black activates his pieces he
certainly does not have any particular
problems after f4 it's it's debatable
what's what like should do there's more
than one good way to play he M decided
to go this route he also could have
taken which is not the most obvious idea
but it's it's interesting if you take F
takes then see 5 and black has very
concrete counter play against the center
and ultimately the king it's not a very
vocal in each position but I understand
his his plan more I mean I prefer but a
broad blade but this was also an ID
empty plate diner f6 as mentioned to get
it to e4 after Bishop f3 and 94 we have
this kind of this kind of position where
both bishops are ya occupying really
dominant positions y term of course has
earned has an extra pawn and their form
is probably slightly for choice but it's
nothing that would would worry me too
much it's black it still looks very
defensible with this excellent bishop
however a couple of moves down the down
the road like place a very strange move
and we see that coming up after Queen g4
exactly here he played a queen to a
seven and this is a bit of a strange one
and hard to understand I'm not quite
sure what blacks idea was on the the
problem with this move and I'll show it
is just rupee two and now this rock has
has a nice be file
and the entry square on v6 which is the
main issue mike has no tactical
operation now to justify Queen a7 and
white will just invade on the B file I
really don't know what what blacks point
was he could could have played um yeah
well everything else is better he still
could have tried to move like c5 for
example opening up or if you go let's
say here just basically playing sit and
wait there's nothing terrible happening
contrary to the game after Queen a7
rugby too and he had this invasion what
is almost winning I mean black has a
hard time to defend the spawns and white
is controlling the only really open file
so I'm would we add vector for playoff
kayaking strength so this is probably
just a win here activated chillin with
the rook and calculated that like he has
a couple of checks check you can always
escape check yeah and here okay we get
to an end game but of course why it is
much much much better because it's g7
that's falling it's just a tactical win
check now I'd here black resigned
there's nothing you can do against the
combined forces of Bishop born and rook
let's say for sure to what should be
played yeah so move then white utilizes
this additional force on the edge farm
and and just wins a bit of a mysterious
game again I'm not not quite sure why he
gave up the B file it's probably based
on some miscalculation
this is quite often the case UMUC move
that on general grounds pretty quickly
am can be judged as yeah as critical as
problematic and very often of course
those very strong players they are aware
of the of the things happening to them
after after they played the moves and
they'll cut how did I allow that and the
very often is based on a simple
miscalculation that you think okay he
cannot do that for some reason and then
you yeah simply recognized that you were
just miscalculated something enter the
plant move this is not not working at
all yeah so I win for kayaking against a
report who didn't really make the most
out of his chances yeah the next game
are going to look at is Dominguez linear
Dominguez from Cuba from Cuba um against
fabiano caruana and yeah yeah it is um
yeah and one issue with this game is
that it is absolutely the longest game I
probably ever covered on video maybe
it's not quite sure but we're talking
about more than 100 moves so um I need
to to adjust to this and i'll briefly go
to go through various structural changes
in the game if i look at each move at
dad will take take ages so just look at
structures and n transformations we have
a ruin lopez and in early d 3 by
Dominguez nowadays the d3 Lions and the
Lopez are very very popular due to the
marshal attack basically this is one of
the various entire Marshall systems it
does not promise wide too much but
the attraction of playing 30 theoretical
moves and the Marshall and then only
have a draw for why this is really
really little so this is a little bit
like that the cards approach to get a
playable position and try to to do
something in a long complicated game ok
b5 and b6 or fairly standard a
three-year black was intending to get
the bishop so you need a square with a
three or c3 you need to give a square to
the bishop castles knights III just
developing and there should be six very
normal type of exchange to relieve some
pressure and we have some morals and now
we see that white has gotten adult porn
and now after 94 we have this this funny
structure where there are many parts on
the hoops that many pawns on the D file
and defect this is the structure that is
happening quite often in this line so
nothing nothing really new after a
couple of more moves we see that white
is gained the a file and in general I
believe that why does some slightly more
comfortable here it's the bishops yes
but also the somewhat more comfortable
structure with the f are being the the
main point of entry after h3h five yeah
note that this pawn is hanging but if
like the black takes it White has the
serve this move down to Queenie five
he's even going to play a form and from
this leads to material losses communi
six rook e1 and ultimately
Bishop is getting the night black cannot
take him so h5 huh note no so playing
against the g4 idea and now why
displaying rugae seven and H fryer note
that after night eggs it's the same so
h4 and Queen f3 and this is really am an
interesting decision why does out of
technical tricks to cover the d5 pawn so
we needs to play Queen a 32 yeah make
sure that this is not lost at first it
looks really weird that this pawn
structure White has doubled pawns
doubled pawns and isolated pawn black
has a bit strange porn age four legs on
Plus this so a very very strange
structure it you know will always be a
bit better for wine simply because of
the activity seventh-ranked and so on
but black soap he has some chances to to
hold the game but it will be an uphill
struggle this is some I think
uncomfortable to play I wouldn't really
have liked a display and we see that
after some more moves we have a further
change the position of black has
activated this night um yeah it's not
really helping if white takes on a for
this needs to be checked but after Ruby
five at the end this pawn is getting
lost and after that it's it's basically
over with any ideas because this frees
up the sea pole and ultimately also make
sure that this bishop will get some more
activity let's say he
it does not need to cover the seat bone
anymore this is why why does not taking
so just Bishop a 3some more repeating
not much happening just a bit of
shuffling and now night supplies yeah
until the funny thing is yeah white
really shouldn't take on c5 as this is
just just too little with opposite
colored bishops so he needs to allow the
capture on b3 and this is one of the
weirdest spawn structures I think I've
ever seen White has doubled spawns
doubled pawns another double porn and h3
is has also isolated and still the only
player playing for when he is white and
this is because of peace activity and
this week in zombie 5 this is a week
pawn and the porn that will get lost
ultimately week and a passive bishop
it's not fun at all for black I'm not
sure he should lose it but it's yeah as
mentioned before not the nice day at the
office yeah what got the ball check go
f5 probably necessary in the long run
and yeah white does not want to exchange
looks the matter of timing at the moment
it's better to have some some more
pieces on but it's difficult in the long
run
yeah without this move you you will not
make any any progress but now White has
some more ideas to activate and we see
that happening in the game yeah rookie
to miss the counter play so he exchanges
rooks and this end game I am not 100%
sure that that it is winning but maybe
it is I mean White has some basically
three witnesses to play against deform H
form and the third weakness basically is
that it's still an extra pond will be
born gaining also space and sort of
tying the King to the c7 phone I'm not
100% sure that it is really losing in
the game it looks fairly convincing this
win but um not not entirely sure this is
the problem zoosk one the bishop cannot
move without giving them one of the
pawns that if you move the king then y
term makes progress with King a5 he in
fact repeats and only now plays b6 and
this is the the key moves check that
makes you yeah that that allows you to
make more progress again and if the King
moves it allows white to enter so you
need to give up one pawn story it's not
so obvious how white should win but he
finds a nice way after getting getting
the pawn in now it's not entirely clear
cut the King here controls this entry
squares and yeah well okay white is two
points it's two pawns up but this pawn
is not worth much at the moment not
really the only way to do to make
anything happen here it's a white going
to the Kings side and I did you can
repeat booth and it's all the time in
the world and now it's going over with
the king yeah like that and this that's
no other way to make any headway then to
play h4 and now even h5 yeah to get a
passer or allow the entry and this
happens with bishop edge for the bishop
trade is yeah obviously losing directly
so after Bishop deform white plays
Bishop e7 and now we get the pawns we
have some transformation shamea yeah and
after Bishop g1 and now Bishop edge to
move 108 camerata resigned wyd will play
King e6 and just combine the 8th porn
with winning the d6 form to win the game
oh yeah I believe that right out of the
opening koala got into a really
uncomfortable structure this structure
is not fun at all to play and maybe he
had some more some some tougher defense
but I cannot really pinpoint where he
should have defended differently it's
just a practical game very very tough to
play alright so only one game left and
this has served the game between the
walk number two and the world number
three
ruyan against my camera let's get to
this game okay I Runion going for a
deform yeah he usually plays some closed
openings varying a bit between c4d 493
so here it's deform and my camera's
joined for the Kings Indian oops this
was the wrong button going for the Kings
Indian one of his main weapons very
sharp opening so we can hope for an
interesting battle aronia is playing the
the classical variation one of his
weapons against the Kings India nice
plate various lines over the years
played the g3 systems here the classical
like him um but he also experimented
with age three lines what I offer play
in blitz um yeah well here the classical
and he's playing with Bishop e3 this is
not a very common choice in his games
normally he's playing that and he also
he had played this against nakamura
before and won a nice game about two
years ago I think here but should be
three is his choice and this is an
interesting line that very often on an
amateur level um yeah catches black
players wrong-footed very often less
experienced players go 96 year which is
a real mistake after D 597 and 92 this
is why it's ideal set up those bishops
active and now be falsified is coming
with the night supporting on c4 and
there are similar positions of course on
the classical that are not
terribly bad for black but note that in
those positions very often white has
castled and here why does not even
castle he just plays all those active
moves and can't keep the King in the
center so there's nothing to attack 96
is a real mistake that Kings Indian
players should know should know about
okay after Bishop e3 black has various
lines he's going from an ID for this is
the most direct move directly attacking
this bishop and forcing the upcoming
sequence Bishop g5 f6 and now the bishop
perm has a choice that it can also go
all the way back to see one this line
has been popular in recent years but
there's nowadays is I think I think
diffused it's not not so dangerous for
black trying to remember why I think I'm
I think it's even that one this has been
has been popular recently with black
activating his pieces this is an
important point with this Bishop getting
active I think this is the reason why
Bishop see one is a bit out of fashion
okay Bishop h4 the main move anyway and
nakamura place your g5 Bishop g3 and
night to h6 this is an outline against
this opening um to plate for years and
to be honest I'm not quite sure what
attracts black players them to the
system because um and instead now you
can just for argument's sake in this
position Black has some other other
moves you can play 96 for example
maybe if not a 6 i'm not sure what i'm
getting at is that this line um yeah
it's a bit problematic due to ya what I
Ronan is playing it's not like it's
terrible for black but it's just very
uninspiring to play if you play the
Kings Indian you want them a bit more a
bit more fun I guess let's see what I'm
talking about is his goal for c5
activating this Bishop and yeah it's a
bit a bit tricky for black what what
should you do now I mean if you take
here and for example d take c 5s is just
terrible you get completely destroyed in
the center if black takes here yeah does
even let's even this move being
interesting check yeah this is very very
strong so promoted by the bishop and
after G for this is the main reply 9h
496 this has been played many times
before we almost by force get this end
game all those traits chat and know why
to give this check and exchanges queens
so this position has been played
numerous times I understand that black
is hoping for relief in the form that
this night on edge for is not ideally
placed and that of course not
controlling the d4 square but on the
other hand the night on age 6 is also
not great note that it cannot easily go
to f7 because of the strong c4 Bishop
and yeah while the night on h4 is not
ideally placed it always has the
sneaking idea to go to f5
so black must be very very careful to
not drift into a somewhat worse position
I think to theory is quite optimistic
here about about blacks play but yeah
I'm frankly I don't like it too much i
mean when i played the king's indian ass
black am i try to avoid those kind of
positions value a sort of bit worse and
you don't really have any active plane
um it's probably nothing terribly bad I
mean I'm not criticizing this harshly
but it's not it's not much fun to
playing I guess maybe Nakamura
underestimated the danger but this is
supported by the fact that after those
moves here with rook da TM he offered
the draw which it seems was quite a
surprise to Aronian and understandably
so because of the trade and Bishop f2
it's a clear that white will never make
it draw in this position because it's
just a little bit better this Bishop is
stronger than this bishop no doubt about
that and there's always this
configuration with night f5 being an
idea and the night bat d placed on age 6
whenever it moves to have certain white
girl goes to f5 and is very happy
without it's just not not fun to play at
all played a six and activated the King
gap the bishop has been routed to e3 met
on g3 it only looked at this pawn chain
not effective at all while on III this
is a nice post you can even think about
taking on edge tix simply because
this would secure the excellent f5
square and at this point I think it's
clear that aronian is some trying to get
a position where he would have a
superior knight on d5 or f5 against the
week bishop and in fact this is what
we're getting here check under the night
is always having listened and reserved
yeah that's that's really a nice
position yeah and here nakamura played
the 96 which I think he after the game
he posted a message on Twitter that he
thought for ages about this move and I
doesn't it just not supported by the by
the clock times well that's curious two
minutes and then 50 minutes yeah it's a
bit strange what the clock times I'd
telling me but what I'm getting at is
that night is 6am seems to to lose the
game he could have played them tougher
defense with King g6 it's very very
uncomfortable playing against those
excellent nights and with those
weaknesses here but this is what he
should have done after 96 White has a
simple move that I wrong I didn't play I
guess I yeah yeah he misjudged the
consequences of it it seems that white
can simply take on bees have made this
effect looks a bit scary because of
nashik four and nine th three because
well it's it's an H form and those are
always very tricky the flank pants if
you have a night BB away under this
those bonds are
quick and den dangerous but here it
seems that white is just quicker if you
look at this before that's a h5 a four
page 45 check it's just much quicker and
let's say after h3 that's always noisy
32 h one if everything else fails you
can stop the pawn in this manner it
seems that white is winning relatively
easily if he takes on b7 however I'm
wrong Leon took only six quite oh I can
wear a surprise it seems and here while
white is of course still more
comfortable it's clear that the other
line was just just a flat-out win and
here it's not clear if it's really
winning I mean I had very similar
positions quite often out of the
exchange kings and yet this is can can
easily happen out of this line this is
this type of structure and it's while it
looks really really terrible this great
night against the stupid looking bishop
um it's not so easy to win I mean the
computer just just to mention it it
gives it as a dead draw but I'm not so
convinced because it's it's still much
nicer to be wide but it's very difficult
to defend in a practical game that
that's that much is clear and we see
that quite quickly to this age 55 that
quite quickly now the camera makes a
mistake exactly in this position here he
he must play and this is necessary must
play King to UM to f7 there's not much
else that he can do he played King
deserve
but this is just directly losing and
that it's by force after night g7 h4
what else yeah it's an attack needs to
cover it and then after ninety three
nights e-form night takes 85 what is
winning the decisive a porn the
difference is that the king is now on
this happen and there's no counter play
at all if he would have gone here this
is not personal narjis happened this is
the first thing to to note if you look
at this this this is of course still
good for white but now there's King g6
and it's not clear how wide is ever
getting this might to to see form you
can try of course to go wire f5 g6 but
this is stupid anyway losing time but
the point is that there's this
counterclaim yeah let's say here and if
white now tries to get to the pawn he's
losing the edge cornered even losing the
game so we could have defended much much
more stubbornly with them with King King
to have seven as mentioned after that we
had this night regrouping winning the a
porn so I'm Nakamura certainly not very
satisfied with this game he sort of
drifted into an inferior endgame and
then after Aronian didn't take the the
porn on oops on the on b7 maybe Nakamura
really had good drawing chances but but
didn't take them yeah so after four
rounds if i'm not mistaken aronian is
leading the tournament
probably shared first place or not I'm
not completely sure some of my brother's
not working it's not starting I want to
look up the standing right okay you can
easily look up the standing on the
official website or other chest new
sites yeah this was round for coverage
I'll be back tomorrow with round five
thanks for watching and yeah until
tomorrow bye